hello and welcome to the shaky science
show in this video we'll look at
conditional protein degradation systems
so to give a more long-winded
explanation to the title of this video
we're going to look at how proteins can
be degraded in a temporarily controlled
manner and how the system can be used in
experimental setups to help you
understand the function of a protein so
we'll introduce a variety of different
ways of developing these conditional
protein degradation systems and look at
some of the good aspects of them and
some of the limitations but firstly a
brief intro to protein degradation so
all eukaryotic cells are equipped with
creating quality control systems so we
know that proteins are encoded in mRNA
that's encoded in DNA as different genes
and so these proteins over time become
misfolded they can get damaged and also
that's bad for a cell to have damaged
proteins in itself so these proteins get
degraded by the 26s pretty soon all the
systems as well and so the idea is if we
want to manipulate the system how can we
promote and switch on and off this
protein degradation to work on our favor
such that we can control the levels of
the protein in the cell to understand
that protein butter
so as I've somewhat already explained
why would we need to do this so likely
one of the most common applications of
these conditional protein degradation
systems is to be able to understand a
protein of interest function in fever
and so we can do this by having a system
that enables us to either remove or to
bring back this protein to see the
cellular phenotype with them without it
so these conditional protein degradation
systems have been referred to as
molecular switches because they're
effectively our tools that enable us to
study a protein when it is and isn't
there and so what I mean by Daren is a
domain that induces degradation so you
can add this egg run domain to a protein
to enable degradation to a car and then
you can make them conditional by using a
variety of different methods that I'll
talks for in this video including
temperature small molecules lights and
the expression of other proteins
in particular I'll fake uh some small
molecules mainly because I understand
out that that I'm have a bit of
experience of actually using these
systems so why would we want to control
protein levels at the protein level as
opposed to the DNA or the RNA level so I
made a phrase that question a bit badly
in terms of the facts if we want to
control the protein level it kind of
makes sense to control it at the protein
level but the thing is we didn't really
have that technology a while ago so the
most common way is to try to understand
the protein with these two literally you
know delete the gene get rid of it or to
knock it down at the mRNA level to
prevent the levels globally of how much
protein that is so the thing is yeah
this technology is pretty recent and it
has some real key advantages so firstly
it's faster if you want to suddenly get
rid of a protein at the protein level we
can get rid of it pretty fast depending
on the system but if we decide that the
gene also starts to knock down the mRNA
levels you know we'd have to wait for
the current protein already present in
the cell to get degraded and to deplete
before we see a global depletion base
and either preventing the transcription
or the translation of the protein the
protein level can also be more specific
so with these egg runs we can
specifically target that Darren as
opposed to genes lesions where you might
have off target effects likewise with
the RNA depletion methods and lastly it
can be reversible so if you decided to
knock out the gene you can't you know
just get that gene back again whereas if
you've got a conditional system that
defeats for a protein level such as
using a small molecule you can add and
then take away that molecule to reverse
the effects of the protein and so the
other thing with it being very fast in
terms of the knockdown is that we get a
direct effect as opposed to a slow
depletion that might introduce secondary
artifacts so we'll come back to this
nature paper later but in the
supplementary they have a very nice
table that summarizes all of the
benefits and limitations to use in these
different systems if you want that
little bit of extra detail okay so how's
that these different systems work so as
I've already mentioned they employed the
use of Terrans
and then they combined it with these
different lights more
whose temperature to make the system
conditional so that you as an
experimentalist can control when you
want to depletes or to bring back your
protein now most of what I'm going to
say comes from this really excellent for
a few article that I'll put a link to in
the description ok so let's start by
looking at the temperature sensitive
conditional protein degradation systems
so at least so far that I think there
are two main systems the TAS Negron and
the Ltd currently are standing for
temperature sensitive they're grown and
so these systems work by altering the
temperature from a lady to a high
temperature the oldest stability of this
leg Ron or the conformational change
that enables the Devron to be recognized
by the protein degradation system
enabling a roughly 30 minute completion
time at least when used on this thigh
hydrophilic reductase
temperature-sensitive dacron which is
around 25 kilo daltons so to go into a
bit more detail from my understanding
these temperature sensitive Darin's
employ the N and rule which basically
means that a protein that doesn't have
the canonical methionine at the
n-terminus
um is gonna be more likely to be
recognized for degradation so if I show
you the figure from there a few
art-school what we can see is that this
I have a late reductase
temperature-sensitive dacron has a
arginine residue asses and terminus and
at the lower temperature this arginine
residue or the licen residues within the
Devron that are needed to be
ubiquitinated for degradation are kind
of hidden or less likely to be
recognized by the degradation system yet
at the higher temperature there's some
kind of conformational change that
either exposes these residues that make
it more likely for the protein to get
degraded nonetheless this requirement
for a temperature change
currently limits its use in mammalian
cells that should really say in
mammalian cells that moles because the
mammalian cell lines tend to grow at 37
degrees so having them at this lower
temperature can have alternative effects
on themselves and also a rapid change in
temperature can have a heat shock
effects on the cells so the phenotype
you see might be reflecting the
temperature change as opposed to removal
or addition of the protein okay so now
we'll look at some of this
molecules egrant systems and the first
one we look at is the auxin inducible
daran system so this is one that
actually I have some experience with so
but arguably the most adults compared to
the others and so this uses as its
inducer as opposed to temperature it
uses aux-in and this aux-in recognizes a
dagger on you got it referred to as an
oxen and useful tech roan which
depending on the manipulation of the
system can either be around 27 or 7 kilo
daltons
and estimates so far well last emotes
experiments have shown that the
half-life of degradation can be around
30 minutes which is pretty good and it
can be used in a million cell lines so
this system has actually been derived
from plants because plants have a unique
degradation pathway that is controlled
by the Olson family plant hormones so
for the system to work for degradation
of proteins you need three components
you need the hormone itself which is
going to be aux-in
you need the dagger on that is
recognized by aux-in and you also need a
third component which is an F Box
related protein called Tier one that
also binds to aux-in and so one tier one
finds to auxin it can then recognize the
dead grown and bring in the machinery in
a Cell that will cause that protein to
be degraded so as you can see here when
the protein of interest is fused to the
auxin inducible Darren in the presence
of aux-in auxin binds to Tier one tier 1
and auxin as a complex come together and
interact with the dead grown and so tier
one also interacts with skip one call
one and RBX one and this brings in or
RBX one interacts with the e two books
and ligase which enables new bikal
donation of the parading of interest and
subsequent degradation so this mechanism
of degradation is conserved between
plants and mammalian cells which makes
it kind of handy for us to use a system
however mammalian cells don't have Tier
one so if you want to use this in
mammalian cells that cell has to be
expressed in Tier one for the system to
work and so the cool thing as I've
already mentioned with the small
molecule Dedmon systems is that you
could add orcas into the cells that
would promote degradation of your
protein of interest
but then at a later point you could
remove that walks in and try to rescue
the phenotype so there's a possibility
of the system is kind of neat
and enables you to in the same cell look
at the phenotype before and then
recovery of the phenotype on and off of
the degradation if that makes sense but
auxin isn't the only plant hormone with
a unique degradation pathway what would
happen if multiple hormones were
employed simultaneously
well this nature paper used a dual
hormone approach whereby they still use
the auxin system but they also use this
new system that they developed and the
reason that this works is because
there's high specificity between the
plant hormone and the dead one and the
airport's protein that recognizes the
hormone so the new system that they
developed in this paper is the Jasmine
it's induced degradation response so
unlike gökçen they use this other
hormone and fused to isoleucine to
isoleucine conjugated Jasmine AIDS they
then have instead of Tier one a protein
called COI one and lastly instead of an
ox an inducible devran
they have aged as they're grown so what
they do want to show in this paper is
that you can now use these two different
degradation systems to control the
protein levels of two proteins of
interest so let's say prudent of
interest a is fused to the aux-in juice
opal degwin and prayed enough interest B
is fused to the Jazz Berggren therefore
if I add auxin for the cells I should
only deplete created of interest a yes
if I adds Jasmine aids a woman then I
should only depletes person of interest
B if I have both hormones together both
proteins should be depleted and this is
what they share in the paper to be
correct which is pretty awesome so
obviously doesn't many ways they could
develop this either to improve its and
enhance their predation rates but there
are many other hormones out there as
well so it's kind of exciting to see
what this technology will lead alright
so it lasts in the molecules egrant
system and going to tell you about in
folks the small molecule shells born as
a shared one combines what Ivor I just
stabilized in domain or it can bind to a
ligand induced degradation domain
and so the nature of both of these
diagrams is very similar and that the
both derived from the fk506 binding
protein and so they both bind to shield
one yet the de state license Maine as
you might have guessed is unstable and
will get degraded unless it binds to
shield one when the protein is then
stabilized on the other hand when shield
one binds to the ligand induced
degradation it causes some
conformational change that exposes the
dagger own and then that bracing gets
degraded hopefully you can see that
clearly in this figure here so the
potentially cool aspect of the system
here is that through the addition of
shield one you could stabilize one
protein and destabilize another so if
you have let's say a wild-type protein
and you can use that to the ligand
degradation domain and you had a mutated
protein of interest and to say the same
price in just the mutant version with
the de stabilizing domain then through
the addition and removal shield you can
vary swap the protein from being
wild-type to mutant and then meeting it
back to wall type we should be a really
neat system to have so the likelihood is
it probably isn't that simple but in an
idealized situation if we plot a graph
of how the protein levels could change
we would see that on the addition of
Shelbourne
we'd see the power type levels go down
and the meat levels get up I'm sorry of
a neat thing with these small molecule
degwin systems is that depending on the
concentration of the small molecule and
there you would be able to have tight
control over the level of the protein in
the cell so if you like added the
maximum concentration to deplete all of
the protein you could do must've range
from the maximum concentration to lower
concentrations but let's say you deplete
half the pretty levels and so that could
also be a very useful thing to use in
experimental systems a dose-dependent
titration you might like to call it okay
so now let's look at light and
conditional degwin systems so one such
photosensitive dagger on which is a
loved to Darren uses blue lights to
induce degradation of the protein and so
this protein has roughly around
- min half-life so pretty much on par
with the small molecule systems however
the use in mammalian cell lines so far
has been a little bit limited so I won't
go into much more detail than this
because the principle is pretty much the
same but the neat thing with the light
and useful systems is that in addition
to the temporal aspect you can also add
in a spatial aspect because of these
small molecules they diffuse in fluids
whereas with light you could like
precisely target specific cells so this
could be really useful for neuroscience
research I lied I have gone to a tiny
bit more detail so you can see in this
like a hair that when you induce the
cells with blue lights there's some
possibly some kind of conformational
change that it spaces the dagger on
which these two used to dis love T
protein and then the protein is and
recognize the degradation so this last
category of conditional degwin fix this
more in the expression of another
protein to induce the degradation
response now this category is very
diverse in terms of different systems
but the one I'll talk about here is
referred to as surf
and so surf stands for split ubiquitin
for the rescue of function so the nature
of the segments play complicate
ourselves being in a second but the key
point is that the inducer here is
rapamycin so technically a small
molecule but i mean it also depends and
an additional protein as well and the
half-life differs again because this
depends on the person itself as I'll
explain in a second but can be used in
mammalian cell lines so happy days so
yep I have shamelessly stolen there were
few articles figure because it looks
nice but we can see if you have your
present of interest and you can see a
fuse to this degwin domain so it has the
Devron domain but it also has a whole
half of the ubiquitin as well it has the
C terminal part of you picked in and so
when you add rapamycin
rapamycin interacts with the degwin
domain and by doing this it also
conceals or well any oh that's pretty
bad words the two halves of ubiquitin so
now ubiquitin can get processed and the
entire dagger one can just be cleaved
off from the prison of interest so in
this case rapamycin actually removes the
tag and the proteins fine but in the
steady state without represent the
protein gets degraded so can you point
number one you all
need the the expression of the smaller
protein this fkb p12 with the n-terminal
parts of cubic sin for this system to
work and the second key point is that
when you have the protein not being
degraded so you in the presence of
rapamycin you have the protein of
interest without any of the dead groans
so that's good because now you've got
your protein but it's also not fused to
anything so that you know these these
egg runs could have secondary impacts on
the proteins function and my defense
it's interacting with certain other
proteins it kids just to stabilize the
protein so this is actually quite a cool
system but has a disadvantage that when
you want to get rid of the protein it
isn't it's some more complicated system
but I don't know that's be honest okay
sort of the limitations then well I've
actually kind of introduced a couple of
limitations along the way but firstly
leading on from what I was just saying
is that we do what there's they're going
to actually affect the function of
operation of interest that wouldn't be
ideal
secondly we you know the targets
Berggren at the moment is often used in
exogenous genes and factors that may be
ever expressed in this protein so the
idea be to get the dagger onto the
endogenous gene loci well it depends on
what you want to do anyway but with
Chris Berg this you know this is
definitely something that's quite
feasible
there's also potentially issues with
using aux-in in mice um something to do
with the liver they metabolize it and
the my Fant happy and lovely speeds I
mean I said already that you know you
can get degradation within thirty
minutes but the fast that you can induce
a degradation you know the more direct
the responses on the cell to that
protein being removed so yeah I mean as
I said the this is still a new
technology and there are many variations
of them already and there are many ways
that they can be modified and improved
so I think you know the whole career is
very exciting and it'd be really
interesting to see what kind of
alternative ideas are develops because I
think all of these systems are really
smart and I kind of you know an envious
of whoever came up with these systems
they're very clever and but yet but
that is really useful and so I think
this this area definitely has a lot of
grades so what's this face I suppose I
know as always hopefully this was a good
introduction and thank you for listening